friends
colleagues
gawking new yorkers
we are here today to celebrate the
marriage of jake peralta and amy
santiago i've known you both for the
last five years and it has been a true
pleasure to watch your distracting
childish rivalry evolve into a
distracting childish courtship and now
into what i'm sure will be a distracting
child is marriage
i'm proud of you
and i love you both
permission to say it back permission
grounded love you sir love you captain
now i believe you prepared your own vows
yes i
was going to do an adam's family-themed
wrap but my beatboxer isn't here that's
the only reason it's not happening so
ames
today has been a crazy day but
i shouldn't be surprised
because we've had a lot of crazy days
there was our first date
our first kiss the first time you told
me you loved me
and the day you told me you would marry
me
also yesterday
and the day before that and the day
before that
because
every single day that i get to be with
someone as amazing as you is crazy to me
i love you
and i'm worried about dancing in front
of our friends
the end
okay well
i've been planning this wedding for the
last six months and if you told me
yesterday everything that was gonna go
wrong
i would have had a panic attack that
sent me into the er
but
i'm here
and i've never been happier
life is unpredictable
not everything's in our control but as
long as you're with the right people you
can handle anything
and you jake peralta
are the right person for me
but i do have some bad news
there is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt
your butt is the bomb there will be no
survivors
i love you so much you're my dream girl
i love you too
i can't wait to spend the rest of my
life with you
ring bearer please bring the rings but i
thought cheddar was sick oh my god
you got the robot there's a robot at my
wedding yeah i felt bad about how
everything went down today so i offered
to help oh that's nice also are you guys
doing the thing where someone gets to
object to this union or is that later
i'm not doing that you've outsmarted me
congratulations okay moving on
do you amy santiago take jake peralta to
be your husband
i do
and do you jake peralta take amy
santiago to be your wife
i absolutely do
[Music]
by the power vested in me by the state
of new york i'd like to announce that
your honeymoon vacation request status
has officially been moved from pending
to approved
you're married you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
i don't know how to tell you this but
we have a little bit of a problem
you know what
the minister just told me that it's
tradition for the bestish mensch to be
older than the groom
oh come on i've never heard of said i
haven't heard of it obviously
but i'm out because i'm significantly
younger than you not significant as a
big word i think you're well okay either
way either way
dwight
i can't be there for you
i'm sorry
jim
i just
really wish there was something i could
do
michael
i can't believe you came
that's what you said
[Laughter]
best prank ever
as is traditional to the shoots the
lovers are standing in their own graves
as a reminder that this is the only
escape from what they are about to do
[Music]
here comes the boo
all dressed and boo
boo lastly nope boo
boo
dude what are you doing i'm being
awesome boo
boo leslie boop my friend i don't think
you understand what a bad idea this is i
don't think you understand that i would
have got a cut of that new punch burger
if she hadn't screwed everything up so
sorry guys this wedding is cancelled
cause the bride is a b-hole hey check
this out stink bomb who knows what that
does oh
stick bomb are you joking oh my god
where did you even get a stink bomb
amazon baby that's how you are looking
at a prime customer everybody two days
free shipping for this guy let's get
this party started with another one gang
no
ah it's terrible jerry you do the
wedding who cares come on man just go
home uh who's gonna make me
it's your wedding day
i'll handle this
here comes the bride
time to go sir no hey get off me what
the hell man did you touch me oh
i'll give you that one
but if you do it again oh if i do what
again what kick your ass is that what
you like you want me to just pout
yay best wedding ever
let's get ready to marry
[Music]
yo check it
this is great at different moments
during our time here we both thought
that tragic mike over here was our one
true love and now he is marrying
whatever janet is i suppose all right it
is a bit
strange i'd like to read a poem
janet my digital queen
janet we can dare to dream send nude
pics of your heart to me
jacksonville jaguars rule
jason when i was rebooted and i lost all
my knowledge i was confused and
disoriented
but you were always kind to me and
according to the central theme of 231
600 songs movies poems and novels that i
researched for these vows in the last
three seconds that's what love's all
about
does anybody here object to this
marriage of course we do how could we
not object overruled
jason
do you want me to be your wife yeah i
want you to be my husband
so by the power vested in me by me i now
pronounce us husband and wife we did it
can i kiss you or will i be electrocuted
only one way to find out
whoa
get some
go get it girl i'm just going with it
now
did you see this it was on youtube
besides
[Music]
[Music]
around you
[Music]
don't be scared i'm right here
[Music]
it's like
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and dance forever
[Music]
feel like we're on another level
[Music]
all you gotta do is watch
me baby
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
you